this Deutschland is Germany ready for an
immigration law I'll be discussing that
with CDU deputy party chairman Armin
lashes welcome welcome to you DW viewers
I'm Alexandra phenomena mr. lucious you
are in favor of an immigration law in
Germany even though that's traditionally
been a taboo topic for the CDU but now
it appears things are changing one major
newspaper has even commented it would be
the equivalent of a minor revolution
within the CDU do you see yourself as a
revolutionary this is not a revolution
in my opinion German migration policies
carry a great deal of symbolic weight
actually we've had a de facto
immigration law in place for ten years
it's called the law and regulating
immigration we have a residence act
we've defined 80 professions that confer
preferred immigration status Germany is
a country that welcomes migrants that
has been part of our national fabric for
some time but we must make the process
clear more transparent and effective
that's what we're currently discussing
but you already favored immigration
reform in your early years as a
politician back then the CDU and its
Bavarian sister party the CSU said
categorically that Germany is not a
country of immigration you've changed a
lot of minds that's true a lot has
changed in the past 15 or 20 years but
that's also a long period of time in the
final years of Helmut Kohl's
chancellorship
a number of young parliamentarians
wanted to modernize the path to
citizenship we felt that every child
born in Germany should automatically
have citizenship many countries operate
by this principle including the u.s.
France and others but in Germany the
principle was that children must be born
of at least one German parent back then
there was little support for change but
since 2000 birthright has been the law
of the
and here too why is it such an important
issue for you convinced that diversity
will make Germany stronger but only if
we recognize the different potential of
people we must allow them to prosper and
have access to training I'm not just
talking about football but one of our
national team players is Mesut özil
nobody is astonished by that fact
anymore even though it's an amazing
achievement but we need the same thing
in politics in management in business
and many other professions that's why I
find this issue so important for a long
time it looked as if Chancellor Merkel
had no desire to pick up a hot potato
like immigration reform how did you go
about winning her over I'm not sure I
have won her over a party leadership
meeting is scheduled for September 14th
but in my estimation she has had her eye
on this issue for some time after all
she is the first Chancellor to invite
migrants to the Chancellery Gerhard
schröder didn't do that nor did Helmut
Kohl nor Helmut Schmidt nor Willy Brandt
in the half century where immigration
has been allowed eckle made the
invitation during an integration summit
in 2006 she brought a female minister of
state to the Chancellery so I think she
has a vision for the future when it
comes to immigration that's the open ds9
almost fog and didn t need so conflicted
what do you think would change with new
immigration laws first we must precisely
define the difference between asylum and
migration
we are currently sheltering hundreds of
thousands of refugees in Germany 400,000
right now with more arriving every day
but forty to fifty percent of those come
from Balkan nations from democratic
countries that are vying for EU
membership they aren't political
refugees but they still want to migrate
to Germany if they knew there was a
chance to immigrate legally they
wouldn't try to enter as refugees and
bid for asylum
making the law more explicit would help
the people and the current legal
processes these class
not on a hill if globish did mention
about him for five and the very moment a
label you mentioned that more and more
refugees are arriving in Germany and
that has inflamed the discussion of a
need to overhaul immigration laws even
though refugees aren't immigrants in the
classic sense of the word
they're people who urge indeed our help
is there a danger that the burden will
grow to large and that Germany will grow
hostile to foreigners yes no I don't see
any evidence of that on the contrary
when you compare the current wave to
what happened in the 1990s I see much
greater willingness to lend a helping
hand it's partly due to the fact that
the conflicts in Syria and Iraq and the
situation in Africa and in the
Mediterranean countries are permanent
issues so there is much more empathy and
a far greater desire to help of course
that could change if there is no end to
the influx of refugees therefore it's
vital to differentiate between migrants
and asylum seekers the situation shows
dramatically how important it is to
update our laws for instance there are
people arriving from Syria they aren't
political refugees but still no one
recommends returning them home but if
that's the case that we must organize
language classes and provide training
and job opportunities so these people
won't be dependent on social welfare for
long rather they will be able to stand
on their own two feet right now our laws
don't provide for that so this is a
third platform asylum immigration and
legislation that allows movement between
those groups in lieu of exit smoothly in
front of mine and instruments mundo but
why isn't that already the case many
Germans feel empathy with the refugees
arriving here but there have also been
incidents of violence directed at camps
for asylum seekers recent surveys also
show that fewer Germans are willing to
accept more refugees in Germany than a
few months or a year ago so it appears
that sentiment is changing as a
scientist doctors to more offices
do you thought there is a danger but I
don't think it's a pervading sentiment
it's true the incidence of attacks is on
the rise and we must do everything in
our power to bring the criminals to
justice society as a whole must make it
clear to those who commit crimes like
arson that they are not representing
Germany as a whole they are simply
criminals that is why it's important to
have fast-track processes to deal with
those who have no claim to remain here
for instance people from the Balkan
nations that will allow us to better
help those who really are in need
immigration reform would be a big step
in that direction let's return to your
Bavarian sister party the CSU some are
making populist claims of massive abuse
of Germany's asylum laws especially by
people from the Balkan nations does it
bother you that the CSU is scoring
political points from the refugee crisis
a few of them bring up the issue now and
then but if you travel to Bavaria you'll
see that the state actually has a very
reasonable integration policy in place
the rhetoric is sometimes somewhat
different from the rest of Germany but I
don't think politicians are using
refugees for their own means they just
have a different method of expressing
themselves but those kinds of remarks
can't help can they right but we don't
have to parse words over every comment
every interview every day I think we are
in reach of an agreement with the CSU
the Social Democrats even the greens but
if we want to produce effective results
we'll have to keep these issues out of
election campaigns it's important that
we don't exploit the immigration issue
in election battles of course
traditionally in political market and
politics is about pragmatism but you
once said that your Christian faith
anchors your worldview how much does
that faith influence your stance on
immigration can't be used too much in
politics but if you're a person of faith
then every individual
is deserving of a helping hand in time
of need the Pope demonstrated that when
he visited Lumpa deucey and spoke out
about the dangers of globalization and
apathy increasingly we see problems in
terms of numbers and facts without
taking individuals into account in the
diocese of Cologne Cardinal vocal
ordered the bells rung in all churches
23,000 times in remembrance of the
refugees who died trying to cross the
Mediterranean that's an example of using
Christian faith to implement policy it's
an influence when we consider
legislation we aren't talking about
abstract numbers or waves or a flood
we're talking about individuals with an
alien of a rights they deserve a just
solution can you think of a story or
personal experience that really got
under your skin one that you can't stop
thinking about as I said there are many
stories but there are a few that I
remember in vivid detail for instance an
11 year old who came here back home the
family was solidly middle class but here
the father couldn't work and the family
was suddenly dependent on welfare
everyone turned up their noses at the
father until he became ill and had
nothing left of his pride and I think
about it all the time I wonder what it's
like for people who are in that
situation right now we must make sure
that we don't repeat the mistakes of the
1990s I feel we are on the right path
there are training slots for those
willing to work with their hands a
stable residency status is also in place
of course there are still legal issues
we must address but the basic goal is
that everyone who is here now can remain
here and eventually become a citizen
personal stories like these make the
case for it as always the DW interview
finishes off with three unfinished
sentences
number one if Germany doesn't implement
immigration reform then then our
cohesive society will dissolve in the
long term of design integration and
migration policy are key issues for
German society people with political
allies need the person who has political
allies as many with similar beliefs you
were hoping for a different answer but I
don't agree with your premise which
premise the saying is that one who has
political allies doesn't need enemies or
something like that but a political
party can achieve many things even if
members have different opinions if I
want a break from politics then then I
turn off my cell phones dang